uh your channel's doing really well you
know congrats
what uh have you noticed because if you
get almost a million views on every
single reaction video like you do social
commentary on a regular basis um how's
your perception of the world change like
what's your what's your world view now
what do you what's some stuff that
you're thinking about
that other people probably are not
tapped into because of how much social
commentary you do
um
[Music]
if you're asking me what's changed about
me i think
um being around preach
uh having the opportunity to it's also
like my time on youtube has been
interesting because i started
really aggressively when i was around 26
and i'm 32. that's been a really big
transitional period in my life i think
i've become much more relaxed i've just
chilled out a lot more
um
i'm not as angry i don't have as many
issues i'm in much better places
i mean that's only been the last year
and a half before that i was still
making 30 40k a year so you have to
imagine the period where most of my
change happened i was still making the
same amount of income and i've been
living on 30 to
40k most of my life either working in
the military running my own business
doing all this stuff it's only during
the pandemic that things blew up because
people don't realize during the pandemic
we went from 120k to one
million so people like oh you guys are
rich now you guys changed this like
breath that's only been the last year
and a half
what do you think i went through 30
years of my life living one way and then
i got to 32 and now i'm a different
human being like they don't they don't
know me like that but my homies who i've
had who have never changed i still got
the same friends from when i was poor to
today we still kick it we can spend time
my family is like none of these people
don't see me as change but everyone
online is convinced i have i'm just like
hey man well maybe
how people perceive you but how is your
your world view change getting married
yeah so so so to that point is it's like
because i've changed as a person in
terms of being much more mellowed out
i'm much more reflective i'm much more
spending time listening which is part of
like why i can't stream because i feel
like i just i talk too much me
personally i can't do it because i have
to spend a lot of time
listening or sometimes i don't know if
you ever have this nico sometimes i'll
talk
and i'll be mid-sentence and i'm like
wait why am i still talking right now
like what the [ __ ] am i even saying at
the moment yeah i have moments like that
and that's when i realized like i might
need to shut the [ __ ] up and do some
reflection um and people meet me in
person sometimes and they realize like
i'm really quiet and i like preferred
listening um and so i think that's like
the being the biggest change i'm just
slower you know i just take my time a
lot more and i just spend more time
listening to people
so i can see the ways rather than being
so antagonistic and sitting across
themselves you're [ __ ] wrong or
whatever it is i can spend time be like
where do we agree here where where's our
common ground where do we disagree and
where can we get to the point of this
[ __ ] and so i'm much better at problem
solving this is like this is even
something i reflected with my
relationship with preach it's like
there was a lot of turbulence uh
business-wise and through a work
relationship initially because const
conflict resolution wasn't something i
was the best at but over the years
having somebody you work with over that
time you have to learn a lot of really
important life lessons
um
and it's taught me a lot in that regard
just like i know how to step back and
listen a lot more nowadays you know what
happened to me when i step back and
listen like i i realize like most people
don't think most people have nothing to
say most people just echo the same stuff
that you see online most people are
virtue signaling and like genuinely like
that's why i get so frustrated and i
interrupt people and i like i'm very i
don't i i don't have that same thing
where you like mid-sense like what the
[ __ ] am i talking about i'm pretty like
set in stone with my world view
i think i genuinely think like i've
taken the red pill i see the truth of
the world and the red pill is bigger
than just women the red pill is
realizing that we're all just pawns in
this game
they're controlling us completely
and so i if i because i follow that i
don't see how you anyone cannot see that
like as a reality like the
pharmaceutical industry the banks the
government everything is all the scam
meant to manipulate and control us
so because i i follow that like i'm
never i never find myself get off track
like i stick to that because that's
i i don't see how that's not just not
the truth that is the truth we can't
trust the government we can't we there
is brainwashing social media is bad for
you tick tock is ran by china meant to
manipulate people and make them all like
change their gender and believe in
nonsense
i understand once i realize that and i
talk to people i'm like oh my god these
people have absolutely nothing original
to say they're just saying so there's
happy happening well this is what i
think about trump and well i don't like
a pro-life pro-choice it doesn't [ __ ]
matter what you think about pro-life
pro-choice we have no effect we can't
change it there's no point in voting
there's no point in putting pro there's
a point of putting blm in your bio
the world is the way it is and the only
way we can act accordingly is taking our
power back
and fighting that
i i'd say this
[Music]
there's a point where you learn that a
lot of things that you've been taught
were lies
so for example in my case i remember
being pushed so heavily to go to school
this is before the internet was like pop
and poppet and i was a 17 year old who
hated academia
and my parents pressured me so much my
guidance counselor pressured me i had
good grades i just
i hated every second of being in school
going to school and then i remember
going to orientation day for university
they let you come in to see what
universities like and i walked in and i
went to a lecture hall and i fell asleep
and i realized like i can't do this
there's no way i'm paying money to go do
this [ __ ]
this is not for me but the whole world
is constantly telling me so i ended up
just joining the military instead my mom
stopped talking to me you know
and it was a tough period
i spent two years in the military
my third year ended up leaving after
that and then
had the money i had speaking to a lot of
my friends from university i saw how
miserable they were
and
four or five years later what i ended up
realizing is a lot of the stuff that
i've been forced to accept as being true
like you need to go to school you'll be
a failure all this stuff turned out to
be [ __ ] and i was angry for a long
time um
and then i get to my latter years and
you know and talking with my parents and
understanding what i realized
wasn't that these people were trying to
feed me a lie
about you
exactly they were trying to feed me what
they thought was which is a guy
hold on hold on hold on it's not that
they were trying to they were feeding
they were lying to me
okay exactly so yeah
that's why i'm angry because everything
people believe
i understand your rage because i've been
there i just want you to hear me okay i
hear you
so when my parents are saying all this
stuff i'm realizing the intention that
they came at me with and it made me
resent them a lot less because i
understood the misconceptions that they
were taught right i
understand it kind of hit me that a lot
of people who are doing wrong things to
me or maybe the way that society's
structured in some ways are doing wrong
things to me isn't necessarily
because they have evil intentions
sometimes
it's obvious there's some obvious stuff
i know that because everybody's
brainwashed it's not their fault they
make no sense they tell us to make no
sense so i'm trying to wake people to
[ __ ] up everything you believe in is a
lie
the government doesn't care about you
school is a scam all the [ __ ] history
books are lies do we need to wake up and
stop letting us letting them control us
i'm not mad at my parents i'm mad at the
[ __ ] system i'm not mad at the dumb
girl who believes in this nonsense i'm
mad at the people who brainwashed them
in the first place
it's bigger than that it's bigger than
just the people in your circle it's the
whole thing
in control does not give a [ __ ] about us
abba
i don't believe that i i i i don't name
one i don't believe that i i don't
believe it
although i don't believe that we have
some right here locally in montreal um
locally
relax man
i do a lot of stuff within the community
that i live in okay i'm involved with
some people we set up community centers
we set up stuff like that really
important stuff that's important to me
we work with government officials who
help us get the funding what i'm trying
to tell you is i understand your
displeasure i understand the fact that
you're like man the government's [ __ ]
up all this stuff what i'm trying to
tell you is that there are still people
that you can work with that can't do
some change locally i think hold up hold
up
breathe
i think people are so terminally online
that they look at these problems on the
whole and they're looking at the canvas
not realizing there's a small picture
right in front of them okay if you spend
so much time online
trying to solve the world issues what
you end up realizing is you can do
nothing because the problem is too
expensive but if most of us
focus on this [ __ ] happen in our
communities okay there's a lot more that
we can tangibly do to make the world a
better place
i'm just gonna finish on this last point
okay
i was very fortunate that when i was a
young man i had somebody who wanted to
help me at a really pivotal point in my
life okay somebody who works in the
government
now when this person helped me they
didn't understand the kind of influence
i would let her have later on
but they unintentionally by focusing on
their community helped to breed somebody
who in the future can help people on a
larger scale i think too many people are
so busy to be like oh my god there's a
typhoon in taiwan oh my god sri lanka is
going underwater there's riots in in
tibet all this stuff it's like brother
you don't even know what's happening
across the street you you ain't been to
your local community center to volunteer
for one hour people are spending so much
time consuming everything everywhere
they forgot to just be in their own
[ __ ] house so
go deal with your family that's why
jordan peterson says go clean your
[ __ ] room okay
they're saying these things because
we're always taking a global approach to
everything well really you just got to
slow some things down so that's but from
the top they're trying to ruin the home
divorce rates are the all-time high
they're telling us to stay inside even
if we'd like go clean up the [ __ ]
trash on a beach then they tell you to
quarantine then they tell you to stay
inside ultimately like yes you could do
local stuff but the top powers have more
control and like yeah okay your local
politicians blah blah blah the
comptroller of montreal shore but they
don't have any power in the large scale
the people who control us the most have
all of the money
like the local stuff going on like it
has a minor effect on what's really
happening and i'm pissed off that the
top people control us more than anything
and people don't realize that so i'm
trying to talk to the people on the
stream and tell them what's actually
happening because people like well the
the mayor of wisconsin bro who gives a
[ __ ] they don't have any power
here's my challenge to you
go get involved in local initiatives
whether it be your community center go
go do some of that [ __ ] okay
go work with those kids who are at risk
go do that
stream it film it i don't care what you
got to do get permission do whatever
do it for a short period of time and
then come talk to me and if you really
felt nothing about that if you really
felt like you didn't influence none of
these [ __ ] lives or didn't do
something for you or you didn't feel
like it didn't matter after that then
i'll concede see now you're doing it not
because it's actually helping the global
problem you're helping it so that you
feel good about yourself for
volunteering i did a good thing today
the problem doesn't change we're all
brainwashed yes you feel good because
you put on a volunteer sticker and you
made some soup for homeless people but
the [ __ ] is still happening they're
taking more and more control and what
they're gonna do is tell us to stay
inside again everyone's gonna be scared
and we're all going to be shaming each
other and they're going to keep trying
to ruin the home by making these women
unwifeable and making the men sad
there's a bigger problem going on than
soup for homeless people
i
i can't speak to what you've experienced
i'm gonna just share one personal thing
that's it
i've had the luxury of mentoring
somebody who
from the
suicide attempts has gotten their life
back together they still struggle but we
keep in touch and we go through that
process you know
little things like that
do i do this for me i'm sure
some portion of it makes me feel good
yeah but i can't deny
that
i'm so happy just for them even if i
never got to see them again even if i
didn't get any updates just knowing that
they good
that i think is important i think
community
helping others
to me there's just nothing
youtube is cool because in a sense i get
to make content and people message me
and that's great but it doesn't feel
nearly as intimate or as impactful as
the people it doesn't feel you're
talking about like the little the how
you feel but it does not solve the
bigger problem that's going on and it's
it makes yes it makes you feel good that
you mentor people stuff like that but
that's one person compared to all the
population that's getting brainwashed
every single day and and imagine if
every one of us tried to make an effort
to help one or two people
you you're you're looking at it as like
i'm trying to fix the world
nico you can't fix the world i don't i
can't i can i can wake up as many people
as possible
you you think you can and and one day
you're gonna realize you can't fix
billions
it's okay
and you're convinced you can and listen
maybe if you're able to do it then i'm
wrong and you're right all along i would
much rather convince people to just take
one step rather than tell them wake up
tomorrow run a marathon my goal is
simply like help the people around you
take care of your family take your
friends do whatever you can and if you
could do at least that much then if you
got enough
help more people that sound like good
but wait till the next pandemic when we
can't even go to the shelter because we
got to stay inside when they tell us to
quarantine and we can't even mentor the
kid because then you're at risk and we
got to stop the spread they don't want
us to do that
there's something bigger going on they
control all of people like that
everybody gets manipulated by their
phone in a second so what we can do the
power we have on social media is to tell
them the truth so people wake the [ __ ]
up
you're being lied to the whole system is
designed to make you fail
to me that that feels better than like
you know giving a homeless guy some soup
that's one guy versus like people like
oh my god i didn't realize this
okay
i i get that i get that and i feel like
if you feel like that stuff is not
valuable then it is valuable it is
valuable but then they're gonna tell you
to stay inside and you can't do that
[ __ ] no more
hey man there's pandemic stuff but um
i'll leave on this note but it's going
to happen again
this is my last point um to anybody
listening sneaker whoever it might be um
if you guys get the opportunity maybe
it's not
um
just giving soup to some random person
but if you guys have something you can
do consistently and try to help out
within your own communities i've just
volunteered to do it i know it sounds
crazy i know you're like why would i
take the time to do it
but i think i
i think there's nothing wrong with doing
it for yourself i don't care personally
i don't give a [ __ ] if people donate a
hundred thousand dollars because it
makes them feel good if you help out
people with a hundred thousand dollars
the people you help out don't give a
[ __ ] if you did it because it feels good
or whatever i'm not one of these people
who believe that altruism has to be done
because you're a [ __ ] saint help
people if you can and if you did it
fantastic i'm not going to question the
reasons why if you want to do it because
it makes you feel better i don't give a
[ __ ] the kid and the people you're gonna
help are gonna be grateful regardless so
if you guys get an opportunity be your
friends be your family just have
opportunity to support the people around
you that's what i would encourage
because not only is it tangible but
you're going to see the progress of the
little things that you do and if you get
to be good at that and you got that down
pat then maybe expand beyond that as
some of my friends do within our
community and i think that [ __ ] is
meaningful even you don't speak you
don't think that you're ignoring a
bigger problem to some extent by by
taking that approach i i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so i
think what you're doing in these kind of
circumstances is you're focusing on
what's in front of you and what matters
you just think that what matters is
different from me and i we can agree to
disagree no i agree that that matters
too but i think that taking that
approach is a smaller impact than what
we can do with the platforms we have we
can wake the [ __ ] up man i i just want
you to appreciate earlier we spoke and i
said
you don't need to be rich to be happy
and you said my agree but you try to
encourage everybody be rich your mindset
translates directly to this you i'm
saying guys help on a small scale you
don't have to be rich you guys can do it
on your whatever you got okay and you're
saying get big get big get big i'm just
saying not everyone's gonna be able to
get big and not everyone needs to not
everyone's got the same size shoulders
do whatever the [ __ ] they want what we
just give soup to a one homeless guy and
they live the life that they want and
control and manipulate us to the extent
that we have no idea about